you wrote a blog post in response to a
person looking for advice about whether
with the Cs degree to choose a nine to
five job
or to become an entrepreneur it's an
interesting question if you just think
from first principles right now somebody
has took a few years in programming has
loved software engineering in some sense
creating python as an entrepreneurial
endeavor
that's a choice that a lot of people
that are good programmers have to make
do I work for
a big company or do I create something
new
or you can work for a big company and
create something new there
oh inside the yeah I mean big companies
have individuals who create new stuff
that eventually grows big all the time
and if you're the person that creates a
new thing and grows big you'll have a
chance to move up quickly in the company
to run that thing
if that's your aspiration what what what
can also happen is that
someone is brilliant engineer and sort
of builds a great first version of a
product
and has no aspirations
to then become a manager and grow the
team from five people to 20 people to
100 people to a thousand people and
be in charge of hiring and meetings and
they move on to
inventing another crazy thing inside the
same company or sometimes they
they found a startup or they moved to a
different great large or small company
there's all sorts of models
and sometimes people sort of do have
this whole trajectory from engineer
buckling down writing code
not 925 but more like
noon till midnight seven days a week
and coming up with a product and sort of
staying in charge I mean if you take
drew a house and dropbox's founder he is
still the CEO
and at least when when I was there he
had not checked out or anything he was
he was good CEO but he had started out
as the technical inventor or co-inventor
yeah and so he was someone who
I didn't know if he always aspired that
I think when when he was 16 he already
started a company so maybe maybe he did
but he sort of
it turned out that that he he did have
the the personal sort of skill set
needed to to grow and and stay on top
and other people
sort of
our brilliant engineers and horrible at
management I I count myself at least in
the second category yeah so you're
you're your first love and still your
love is to be the quote-unquote
individual contributor so the programmer